to work was when natalie hart was like
this lying down and it was like well
who's gonna lie after her because i'll
be gone and dying and she's like
she won't be alone
so harlequin romance if you know
harlequin romance it was so happy
hello hello hello everybody and welcome
to another episode of the after show i'm
nikki novak and i'm so excited because
today we're going to be talking about
thor love and thunder yes
uh we're going to be deep diving into
the show
talking about all those details and then
answering the burning questions that the
film
left behind now i should warn you
this is going to be a spoiler-filled
conversation so if you have not seen
thor 11 thunder maybe go check out the
film and then come back or if you enjoy
that type of conversation having
everything spoiled stick with us but you
have been warned just look into the eyes
of the people that you love
[Music]
not me
what i am
so excited because i've been wanting to
meet this person
talk to this person content creator tech
whiz person with the best haircut in
hollywood brian tong how are you wow
nikki that that's a lot to live up to
but i do i do appreciate the intro so
happy to be here and uh i'm ready to
jump in this with you this is the first
time that we've done something like this
so i am excited as well i'm excited too
and i'm excited to hear your thoughts
about i know i i've sort of watched some
of your videos before and i've got your
impressions on other films like sean chi
another one so i'm
so curious to know what you thought
about this film but before i get your
opinion brian we're going to talk about
the critic score and the audience score
on this film the tomato meter is 67
fresh and the audience scores 81
the critic's consensus is in some ways
thor love and thunder feels like
ragnarok redux but overall it offers
enough fast pace fun to make this a
worthy addition
to the mcu so now drumroll please
brian
do you want to occur
with the critics or audience score or
neither
i nikki concur with both
because when i saw the movie you know i
saw the movie on the premiere night and
there's a lot of energy around it and it
was fun and it was like the first time
it's exciting like oh this is a fun
movie and then i went to see the second
time you know with the regular audience
and it kind of i like to see a movie
twice because it kind of grounds you a
little bit gets you away from the hype
and i think the score is right because
if you go into this movie and you just
want to have a brainless good time and
just sit back and enjoy it's fun there's
a lot of laughs there's a lot of like
great visuals but if you look at it from
a critic's perspective of how the
characters developed maybe where they
could have done a few different things
story wise that we'll talk about later i
think the lower critic score does make
sense and i wanted to actually see a
little bit more evolution of the
character kind of like what we've seen
with with iron man's journey captain
america's journey i mean those are big
moments every time they had a solo film
and that's why they you know they hold
such high regard in the mcu
i don't think we got this from thor and
so that that's partially also why i feel
like it it missed in some ways as well
i have to ask you now are you a gemini
by any chance
no i'm an aries what makes you think i'm
a gemini because we're very still i'm a
gemini and i have to watch everything
twice i also was at the premiere and
then i went to watch it again
yesterday in a theater with a general
audience and i saw it in 3d because it
was the emptiest theater because every
seat was filled and i just tend to like
my space
so i'm like i guess i'm going to see in
3d i was a little bit reluctant but i
have to say i was the flip of you
so when i saw it at the premiere
listen i laughed so hard i had so much
fun especially with like the first two
thirds of it
but also at a premiere i'm always a
little distracted like i've thought
about i'm thinking about when i sit down
conversations i had on the red carpet
and all that so i always especially when
i've seen it at a premiere i need to see
it again and like you said see it with
an audience and sort of see their
reactions because at a premiere
but at the premiere i was leaning
heavily on the humor because you're
there to have a good time right like you
want to have fun you want to hear the
audience roar and that's where you're
going to hear it was when you know
everybody's jacked for the premiere
um
but then the emotional beats didn't hit
for me because i was like oh forget the
emotional stuff i still have a good time
and then when i watched it in
a theater yesterday in 3d which by the
way i highly recommend watching this
movie bring back 3d i
had a better time with it the second
time around because the humor still
landed but i saw it more as a whole
story and the evolution of the story it
felt a little disjointed when i watched
it in the premiere but i think that was
just my brain just
going in and out of focus so i actually
liked it better the second time around
and i tend to concur
more with the audience overall i feel
like i like this
pretty much on the level with ragnarok
and i think part of the problem we'll
get more into it let's let's i want to
ask you more questions about this before
we before we before i go too far into it
we could just talk forever so yeah we do
have to follow some level of like
okay so let me just say that the box
office did great i was 143 million at
the box office domestically the third
biggest opening of the year and
302 worldwide so first of all so let's
go more into the humor of it and what
you thought of that because there are
sort of like i feel like people are in
two camps they're either they love the
humor of it because they love the
ragnarok aspect they love that he might
have even gone further with it
but then they felt like
they didn't like the drama side or vice
versa i've heard a lot of people say to
me oh i like the drama or like i didn't
i like the drama aspect of it i thought
the humor and the silliness got in the
way so which side were you on
i i mean this is one of those few movies
when you ask if i'm a gemini i think it
kind of it honestly almost comes into
like what's your frame of mind going to
this film because everything we talk
about on both sides of the coin of this
movie i completely agree like so first
of all if you loved ragnarok i think
you're gonna be bought into the tyka
style the tech humor which there's a
joke on top of a joke and then the third
person gets in on the joke and sometimes
that can be fun and sometimes that can
be tiring and i don't blame either side
for which perspective they take i think
the humor
for me
i enjoyed it i laughed my ass off the
first time you know the second time
obviously not as much and i'm i'm kind
of just you know seen it a second time
and i'm like i don't know if this is a
movie that i could watch multiple times
like i have a lot of other mcu movies
quite honestly i think like two was good
enough for me but the humor does it you
want to feel good when you come in but
then it's almost so much they do humor
in like semi-serious moments they drop a
joke in serious moments that then when
they actually try to
get you the serious emotional stuff you
you're kind of off balance and you're
almost expecting it to go in another way
because they've done this the whole
movie and then you're like oh i this is
actually an emotional time where i do
need to lock in and pay attention so
it's hard it's hard for me to say
whether it was bad or good because there
were times where i loved it and there
are times that i didn't and i think that
is reflected in the score but from a box
office standpoint i mean i believe this
is the best performing thor movie of the
four up to this point so that hasn't
heard it and uh like you said third best
box office move the year so far so um
people are watching and join it um we'll
we'll see how that long tail happens but
um
i i i'm more of the side of the humor
heard it a little more than it helped it
for me
um so what okay so tell me like your
favorite comedic moment and maybe one
that didn't work oh god foreign
favorite comedic moment i mean i think
the intro was the yeah i think when
thor's doing the splits between two
motorcycles and holding that pose
extremely long i mean that probably got
the biggest laugh at i mean i mean it
was that's ridiculous you're like oh
that's like tycho saying like we're here
get ready buckle up and so
i love that moment um the ones that
don't land i think there's too many too
many korg like
korg always had to say something
between one of their jokes he like
always did and so
taika this is his movie that he directed
tyke also made sure he put a lot of
himself in the movie too but this is his
movie so i can't complain about that if
that's what his vision was so i think
that sometimes korg
messed up
the the emotion and some of the scenes
because there's too much of them
well there wasn't enough of him in some
scenes because he was just a head which
i don't know if i loved that part of it
like i was a little disturbed by it i
thought i don't know if i'm enjoying
just coring just being ahead i'm curious
how that all came about because it
didn't really service the story in any
way other than in the zoo scene when
cork's head was tied to the back of
tessa thompson's head
that was hilarious i thought i'm sorry
i'm making the mustache and everything
yeah yeah and if we're talking about
favorite moments hands down
that was my favorite scene i thought
russell crowe as zeus which i heard tyka
say in an interview recently that they
had him film
two takes of every single
part of his performance once in a
british accent and once in his
quote-unquote greek accent and they
showed it to test audiences and hands
down and that was russell crowe's idea
to do sort of like a bad greek accent
i thought he
crushed it
he was really fun
i loved
the humor in this movie i thought chris
hemsworth and i said this in my twitter
reaction after i saw it the first time
that i think this is chris hemsworth's
best performance if any film he's ever
done and people were coming at me going
how can you say that because i think a
lot of times when people say
best performance they immediately think
drama that you have to go to drama to be
rewarded for like a great performance
i've never seen him more comfortable
more in his element he's clearly taika's
muse
they work so well together even better
than ragnarok i just felt this
comfort in his skin like he just felt
he's never looked better
by the way some of those arm shots had
to be seen ridiculous no way that he was
that big and i don't really care i'm not
a wash washboard ab person or an arm
person i don't get i'm sure about that
you sure about that nikki
i promise you i'm probably i have my
moments but i definitely had my moment
with chris hemsworth in this one i was
like oh my god
um but i thought though i thought the
zeus
that whole scene was hilarious but i
also loved chris hemsworth sort of
when he was sort of forlorn about his ex
which was the hammer the mueller being
like coming in and sort of like all of
that all of those jokes and then his
current hammer getting jealous i thought
that all landed okay so i've gone on
enough about how much i love thor and i
love chris hazard oh really about his
performance
i had no idea that you enjoyed thor and
chris hemsworth the character nikki
look i think if there's any a-lister in
the entire mcu that is like
you know the the one that is has the big
the biggest on their shoulders
figuratively and literally uh it's chris
hemsworth i mean he
no one personifies thor better than him
i don't i can't think of a single actor
in the entire
world universe that could be thor and
we've seen him you know they talked
about actually in the past after
thor ragnarok hey he has a lot of range
you know you he does comedy really well
but he has a lot of range and i thought
we got to see more of that in
him dealing with jane specifically at
the hospital when she had cancer i was
like oh man like i felt goosebumps in
that scene like that is so important for
us to be able to see him do that just
moving forward knowing if there's big
stakes at the table that we can see this
from
thor who sometimes comes off as a bumbly
muscle head but who actually has a real
heart inside of him so incredible work
by chris hemsworth i think that um also
let's not forget when he does these
scenes between
stormbreaker and milner
he's talking to inanimate objects like
grazing by his head or sitting on a
table and it's some of the funniest
stuff in the film so
it just shows how much range he has and
um
i loved everything about his performance
and there's nothing that he did
wrong his thor
crushed it crushed it the one and i'm
i'm probably not gonna
make myself very popular saying this the
one comedic performance that didn't land
for me was when natalie portman's
character told jokes
i it and she didn't do it often but that
scene where she's like i'm trying to
come up with my catchphrase
yeah that didn't totally land for me but
she's not known to be a comedic actress
like i forgave her for it because i
thought she was awesome and so much of
the rest of it but if there was any
humor that didn't work for me
it was unfortunately her i thought
all the other humor landed for me and i
actually wanted even like i would have
even loved if it carried on to the end
because the end got quite heavy
um so what did you think of natalie's
performance
well you know being someone who
again i know these movies are made for a
general audience and not for like it is
derivative of the comic book stuff but i
thought you know i'm a big comic book
geek i mean i read the story lines of
gore you know the god butcher and
mighty thor before this was any movie
stuff so i thought that
natalie portman's performance the
strength that she had in the
vulnerability was incredible i actually
kind of wanted to see a little bit more
of her journey um to give more gravitas
to it that's that's interesting because
i thought the exact same thing i almost
thought that this should have been a two
film arc for her character
and maybe technically you know she only
signed on for one so they put it all
into one story but i really felt like
maybe the drama of it would have landed
more
had we really built up and sort of maybe
not had
you know her pass away in this film
maybe in the next film and in this film
almost have there because we didn't see
her in ragnarok right so we hadn't
really seen those two together as a as a
romantic couple
for a while a good number of years and
when they kissed and got together i
almost felt like it was too easy like i
like i got i got because he made a joke
in the beginning saying
she's like how long has it been and he
says eight years in two minutes and he
knows exactly to the minute
but i wasn't sure if i still saw why she
was into him they didn't there wasn't
time to sort of build that relationship
it was all very quick
and so
then you know to see her come into her
own and i thought her scenes as
the mighty thor were amazing oh insane
they're freaking awesome
freaking awesome right she looked
amazing she just owned it
and i just thought
i would have liked to see more of her
owning her power and then maybe in the
next film see her demise and and then
they would have had more time to build
on that humor i don't know how you feel
about that but yeah so tell me a little
bit about yeah so how did you feel like
you you touched a little bit about on
christian bale's performance as gore
and i'm just curious how you felt
it worked how you felt it didn't work
and given that you're so familiar with
his story in the comics what maybe you
would wish they would have leaned into
more from the comics
so i think right off the bat he doesn't
get enough time in the movie to show
just how savage he is you know we see
him kill that first god we see some gods
die here and there but he
he brutal like his his history is
brutalizing the gods with reckless
abandon i mean he spends a little bit
more time with the kids than he does
butchering gods and i think that would
have brought a lot more gravitas to it
the the reality is that and again this
is not for
you know in the comics it takes three
thor's from three different timelines to
try and even defeat gore the god butcher
like that's how big of a villain and
that's how much power and fear he
strikes into it um at uh is it only
omnipotent city is that is that where uh
zeus's um scene is omnipotent yeah yeah
i think so yeah
i wrote that one down too right i was
like so when that whole scene happens
they're not even intimidated by gore
they they of course they overlook what's
happening but we don't as an audience
see enough of the brutality and power of
gore the god butcher
thanos
had his time over the course of several
movies and over a build up of movies for
us to fear him right but i think that we
needed to fear gore more and at the same
time christian bale's performance one of
the one of the best villains we've ever
seen in mcu like his range showing his
um
displeasure and how he was hurt and
betrayed by the gods
i actually i like that intro off the
gates to establish when you establish a
villain in the beginning before the
actual movie you at least get their
motivations going so i thought that was
great but christian bale was fantastic
as gordo the god butcher you there's
obviously like stories about how they
changed his look
he was fine he looked great he was scary
as hell but i think they really needed
to make that um to make the death have
higher stakes they needed to develop
gore more than they did okay so now i
want to ask you about
the end beats of the film because we did
get some drama
how did you feel about the way that the
film wrapped up
um gore's arc and sort of how where gore
ended up in the film
um in general see i believed because
christian bale is so good at acting
i believed his turn emotionally right
we talked about a little earlier i just
wanted to see
more
from him to
make that scene feel like we had a more
of a history with him that happened
to maybe even another nod
to some sort of interaction with his
daughter that really nails that home um
but
when he
basically relinquishes him from being a
selfish person wanting to kill all the
gods
i felt maybe we just needed a little
more something to know about how he
really came to that decision in those
few moments but christian bale is
incredible doing it so
it didn't feel like forced or out of
place so i loved everything that i saw
there and also just how the fact that
right so christian bale's daughter
it's all about love
thor becomes the uncle too
i guess the manifestation of his
daughter who is now in has the powers of
eternity in her to shoot
purple laser beams out of her eyeballs
um i think the whole crowd
when they showed that last kind of
monologue and they said love and thunder
and they both jump in the air like that
was a really good film like feel good
moment that was heartfelt and so i don't
know if we're gonna see her in future
films i mean it would seem
she has the power to hang with
superheroes in this mcu
but i don't i don't know if we'll see
her it is i mean i didn't know this
until recently that that was actually
chris hemsworth daughter
playing that role and once i found that
out maybe if i don't want to know
everything before i go on a film but
maybe that would have changed even just
emotionally how i felt about it but now
when i look back at it i mean
those are awesome moments so
we'll see how where she comes into play
in in the mcu i don't think it'll be a
big role but
i thought it was just really satisfying
that the title of the movie tied in the
fact that it was her and crimson source
together and jump in and it was awesome
you just gave me chills you just gave me
chills because when you finally
find out years later from when they
announced the film
who the love was in the love and thunder
that was brilliant i loved that it was
his daughter whether or not we're going
to see her again i think highly depends
on how much chris hemsworth's daughter
wants to be an actress because i think
we can see it moving forward
i don't know if it was one of those
things like look but i thought because
that is his real-life daughter they had
great chemistry i thought she was
amazing i didn't even realize it was his
daughter until i read that later they
don't necessarily look alike
so i was like oh my gosh who's this
young actress she's really great she's
got a real strong presence i love the
scene at the end i just yeah i thought
the way that that wrapped up the only
part for the film that didn't work for
me
was the last scene with bale and i'll
tell you why because it got dramatic no
not just because it got dramatic because
how did he shift on such a dime like
that like
why was
i it was basically like
he you know thor was his enemy
throughout he hated the gods he hated
the gods that was his whole motivation
and just at the very end hemsworth is
like choose love and he's like okay i'll
just go okay let's do that and then the
moment that really didn't work was when
natalie was like this lying down and it
was like well who's gonna lie after her
because i'll be gone i'm dying and she's
like
she won't be alone
harlequin romance if you know harlequin
romance it was so like oh jeremiah i was
just like she was dying and she's like
oh he'll look after her it'll be cool
and he's like cool this arch enemy is
going to take his love his daughter that
motivated him throughout to be filled
with so much hate because he lost her
i hate the gods so much it just was too
quick that part did not work for me
i
that's why i was like i said hey
we could we have seen just one scene
that might have given us a little inside
that or like an easter egg that would
have led to that decision in that moment
right that's all we needed to see to for
us to buy it you know more i think the
other thing that maybe the directors
will say is like but he was infected by
the necrosword and was not in his right
mind when he hated thor all that time
and so now that it left his body i'm
just making this up in if i was you know
being interviewed about this it left his
body so therefore he was more rational
in those moments because that was the
real gore we saw not the infected gore
god the butcher but i still didn't
you're right everything you said is
right
i mean it was still bail he's still
grave still poor when he was still thor
um
yeah it but yeah that moment for me i
was like
that that seemed comedic
that seemed comedic but not
intentionally
that was the comedy that did not work
for me in the film the rest of it was
just fine
see that's why i told you go ahead
can i just say one more one more thing
chris hemsworth can we give him one
shout out for not like leaving the mcu
and he's like i'll do another film i'll
do this role for 20 more years if you
need me to like evans is like i'm out i
need a really good reason to come back
robert jenny jr tapped out a long time
ago he's just ready to go for more
hey i mean we we've seen this is by no
means comparing the franchises but the
fast and furious keeps calling that cast
a marvel keeps calling chris helms are
he going to keep showing up
he is the vin diesel
for the mcu
you better be careful there you better
be kept there 20 years from now
hemsworth will be saying we're family
that'll be this cash phrase in the mcu
and he'll have like the russell crowe
dad bond
it's going to happen it's it's our it's
already written and i will be there for
it
anyway but yeah i also agree
that you know so i'm curious because
again you're so
you know so much about the comics you've
spent so much time like this is in you
know according to the tomato meter like
in the lower like i think the bottom
four in terms of the score in the mcu
um
going into this film not knowing what
was going to happen but knowing the
comics what were you maybe do you
understand why the score is lower and
what were you sort of hoping to see
overall what were you expecting to see
that you maybe didn't
well we like kind of touched upon i mean
i really think this is two movies for
two different audiences as as a fan who
loves the mcu i think you're gonna rate
this pretty high quite honestly but as a
critic you're probably going to be
a little like where where's give me some
give me a little bit more meat and
potatoes along with the comedy right i
think that that's where the score falls
let's talk about some of the other
characters so valkyrie uh tessa thompson
what did you think of her i thought
personally i thought she had the best
moment in the film when they were in
with zeus and he she went to one of the
handmaids and sort of like kissed her
hand i thought that was that's my film
that was hands down my bear i thought it
was so much fun
she
is incredible the camera loves her
everything she delivers she doesn't seem
like she's trying too hard she doesn't
seem like she's reaching she's just cool
and she's a great actress
and every time she was on screen my eyes
went to her what did you think man i
fell in love with tessa thompson when i
first saw increase
i fell in love with her and i think that
you know because i feel this way about
tessa i wanted more tessa i think that
valkyrie
should have been in this movie more i
know there's so many different elements
but
was based on how the movie was set up
with the characters in focus
yes it was awesome and sometimes when
you have a character like valkyrie who
doesn't get enough shine you want more
and that actually bodes well for the
future of what they could do with her
character but i wanted to see more of
her
in this movie i just want to see more of
her in general uh even you know clearly
she was bored being king of asgard on
earth doing all the political things and
doing old spice commercials
and she just wants to go out there and
kick some ass and we want to see her
kick some ass and she has that like
confidence and that sass and that
strength and she's a badass so do i want
to see more badass tessa thompson
yes and i hope that based on how people
reacted to her role here saying like we
wanted more we want more that they
deliver on that down the road
i think i don't know why they haven't
announced her own standalone phone yet
i'm so surprised that that hasn't
happened yet
she could carry it she could easily
carry it and everybody loves her like
she and she's proven herself and she
shines in every single no matter which
mcu film she's in she's always been a
standout like people have always talked
about her um did you miss loki oh who
doesn't miss loki i mean i think that
there's something
it's like peanut butter and jelly like
thor and loki that that that's what we
got we've gone to in the mcu but loki
has has his own thing going on yeah
it'll be fun when they bring them back
together i think you sometimes you know
sometimes you don't want too much of a
good thing right you know that pb j is
really good but you don't i mean i don't
need it every day but uh i think that
loki and what's going on with the
multiverse and the timelines
they will eventually come back together
and when they do it's going to be
awesome so it's okay that loki wasn't in
it but do i miss him absolutely i mean i
think a lot and you've referred to this
like thor ragnarok when we talk about
that movie i think part of it is also
that movie kind of came out of nowhere
you know it changed the tone
of thor i mean it reinvigorated the
complete thor franchise it brought a new
you even talked about like a new flavor
a new texture to the mcu where you can
have a space that is jokey and safe so
i'm not saying get rid of that but just
the the way that thor ragnarok was built
the visuals because of sakhar the the
off world where hulk was um world war
hulk or was you know hulk the warrior
was happening um that
visually
musically
and comedic-wise was kind of like this
is this is thor and i think it parsley
was
in a way maybe taika was trying to
capture some of that but also not and it
made it hard like people feel like oh it
was a little bit of a redo of of
ragnarok but it wasn't you you can't
replicate everything that ragnarok was
and if you tried to it would seem less
impactful and maybe
some of that
thor ragnarok shine because it was so
great
maybe people were like okay i've seen
some of this before it didn't feel as
fresh because that movie came out of
nowhere from the mcu
see i think and i was i've been
wondering this ever since i saw this
film
if it had been reversed and you had seen
this film before ragnarok
i wonder how people would feel because i
think when something is lightning in a
bottle
and
you've never seen anything like it
before we had never seen that type of
humor in the mcu with the exception of
guardians
but taika has his own style of humor and
flavor so to see all of a sudden if we
had seen this film first and ragnarok's
second how would people be reacting
because sometimes when it is that
powerful and that lightning in a bottle
it is really hard to follow up
that said some of the visuals and some
of the like the the opening scene i
thought was the best scene in the entire
yeah it was badass the goats
and see
like apparently the goat sound came out
of a taylor swift meme
because people thought it was tyka's
voice
but somebody had heard the goat sound
and they were initially going to have
those screams
every time it got me even towards the
end when it was getting dramatic and
they you know crash landed it worked it
worked for me every single time i love
tyka's humor
i think
if i'm going to say anything about this
film in terms of structure and storyline
i think
maybe the transition from comedy to
drama isn't seamless
do you know what i mean like i think he
can do both
but maybe the transitions and how it
flowed wasn't as seamless as ragnarok
but other than that i thought
like i said i love i loved the comedy
just as much if not more
do you do you think though the
transition was harder because
they really went like so hard of the
comedy because when i when i watched
thor ragnarok i loved it because new but
it didn't feel like they were forcing
too many jokes i felt like in this movie
they were they're pushing the joke on
the joke where in ragnarok there was the
joke and it was funny but here in um
in love and thunder there was the joke
and then they would add another joke on
top of it and so that's where i think it
might have been a little extra but but
i what do you think about the fact that
because it was pushing so hard to comedy
that it made it harder
to transition into more dramatic stuff
um
i think with ragnarok you had
way more of the avengers
and you had each of them sprinkling in
humor
i think the humor fell on the shoulders
of fewer people in this one
[Music]
and
i think what chris hemsworth does with
thor is magic
he's
amazing and he is thor embodied yeah and
was it chris evans who recently said you
know there is no nobody else could have
played this role
uh and he's truly he's truly great i
think maybe yeah maybe it's because
it's not embedded in the sort of phase
three mcu that we're used to and so it's
i think you know marvel's finding its
way with these new movies and i think
you know those past ones they always
they were building on a story right like
there was an end game this sort of feels
like its own movie and i do believe i
have a lot of faith that all of these
movies in phase four are gonna
eventually come together shaun chi
eternals
this one i think they're all gonna come
together because they're planting little
seeds of how it's all going to come
together in the end but i think it's
harder when it's not the doesn't feel
initially like it's
part of like a whole storyline i thought
maybe maybe thor ragnarok felt like it
fit into the mcu more so maybe there was
more of story that was continuing
where this is just more of like its own
little one-off and it didn't necessarily
connect to the larger picture in the mcu
so maybe that's why
um i think i think you're touching on a
great point though because you know we
talk about the connectedness of the
story some people are you know you hear
some buzz of oh are people
mcu fatigued right now right like are
people tired of this is this look the
movie's still doing great numbers so
let's let's not i would say
i i don't i think those are a little
played up to maybe you know get some
clicks i don't think people are tired
per se but i think what you're seeing in
the mcu is that
because we haven't had a clear direction
of where exactly we're going whether
it's you know this new secret wars
direction or whatnot people
people forget though when the mcu was
establishing itself
it took basically what the first five
years to establish these characters to
give them enough threads and
connectivity for us to then buy in so if
we look at this phase four as kind of
like the second generation reboot
we need to get to know these characters
a little bit more from a standalone
standpoint i think yes we know thor a
lot we know dr strange a lot and maybe
because we didn't feel like hey those
are types of movies where maybe we would
see more of that connective tissue and
it didn't happen maybe sometimes people
are disappointed i think another trend
that's happening because we haven't seen
this um
at least everything
right in our face laid out of what's
where kevin feige and the mcu want to go
is that people kind of get even more
excited about the end credit scenes
than they do about the movie at times
just kind of wondering what's that next
thing er the mcu has
built this huge hype train and phantom
that everyone just wants to know the
next thing and when they don't give you
the next thing allah where is the mcu
going they feel a little bummed and then
instead they lean in like this cameo is
great and some people like dude it was
just a cameo where are we going so i
think i don't think it's fatigue i think
it's really people don't exactly know
what i think it's a good thing they
don't exactly know where the mcu is
headed yet
and once they feel like oh okay i'm on
board with this then i think it changed
the tone of these movies and right now
do they feel disjointed yes but i also
remember
iron man 3 was not very well received
but the trauma that tony went through in
iron man 3 if you watch it again years
later plays into the future if you watch
age of ultron which people didn't like
when it came out but now you see the
establishment of scarlet witch and her
journey and other aspects of the
relationships in there people now say oh
i actually enjoy age of ultron more
because of where the stories went so i
think that
until
kevin feige lets us down which they
haven't
um
we need to give them the benefit of the
doubt for creating this epic 24 25 plus
movie franchise that we all love and
wait for the pieces to fall instead of
having a knee-jerk reaction and being
like this sucks or i just care about the
end credit scene i think that's the
wrong way to look at this
i think you make excellent points and
yeah if you hear about any sort of
marvel fatigue i'm i've actually really
enjoyed
phase four in the sense of i've enjoyed
these one-offs
and i enjoy sort of speculating as they
sort of as the films wrap up how they
are all gonna fit together in the bigger
picture and i fully believe
that when we get to the end of phase
four everybody's gonna be like
oh my gosh
i did not see that coming they tied
eternals into this and into that and i i
really think that they're laying the
seeds i don't think it's as
laid out like you said it's a little
more obscure at this point
and they're starting to like
yeah
yeah i agree like i think it's okay and
i think we are going to see it tie
together in kevin feige i trust
um
so let's talk about the mid credits
scenes because you touched on it so what
did you think
first of all about the fact that zeus is
still alive i'm all on board with that
i'm so happy oh heck yeah give me more
zeus come on i i'm on board with that
for sure yeah
yeah go ahead
oh sorry so the end credit scene where
zeus is alive and repairing his somehow
thunderbolted chest that went through
his entire body um and
the thing about is like when you've i
had to actually watch the movie twice
honestly more because there are times
where
i didn't really hear what zeus could
said in the premiere because not only
are people laughing a lot like it's kind
of hard to understand like because of
you're saying he's doing a trash greek
he's doing a trash greek accent
so if you're gonna do that it you had
have to like listen
so the second time around
it made it easier to understand him as
well but the reveal
of him you know basically saying people
don't look at our gods anymore they look
at superheroes more and it pisses him
off and he brings in
hercules but not just hercules we're
talking brett goldstein from ted lasso
and what's interesting like
at the premiere people went buck wild
but i think at the general audience
because not everyone has seen ted lasso
but everyone hears about how amazing
that show is i don't think people
understand how genius
that casting for someone to go mono e
mono with chris hemsworth and that humor
and that gravitas how genius
that casting is going to be
for hercules um who historically in the
comics they were rivals they actually um
had beef over jane like as a love
interest they end up becoming friends
and bros but that's an evolution that
we're going to be able to see on screen
of hercules coming to kick thor's ass
you know they're both cocky we know they
both think they're the greatest gods
because they're both sons from gods
hercules from zeus thor from odin um so
whatever happens in thor 5 i think that
dynamic is going to be special and you
always need someone to play off a hero
to make the movie that much greater and
i freaking can't wait for whenever that
happens uh that could be bonkers
bonkers i agree i'm the ted last so fan
i watch i love fred goldstein i love his
performance my favorite character on the
show especially in the last season i
just think he's incredible and i was the
same like in the premiere i was like so
excited everybody went crazy and then
you know like i i i test a lot of what
peop what i sort of like because we're
all in this business and we all
understand a lot and know a lot and
watch everything i asked my nephew who's
11 is an mcu fan would you think of
hercules and he's like who is that guy
he doesn't watch that lasso he doesn't
know he had to explain who it was and he
was like cool like he's on board with it
but it wasn't of course when you watch
it with an audience
you don't get that like whoa you're kind
of like the people are yelling you're
like you watch ted lasso and you over
there who aren't reacting you don't
watch ted lasso but
100 he i cannot wait to see where it
goes now when you talk to when you just
mentioned in the comics that they sort
of fight over jane that's something
i would love to see i know i know and
unless she somehow comes back but i
don't i don't think it's gonna happen in
that in that form but um it would have
been you know you had the
i mean sometimes i forget like the whole
the whole milner and stormbreaker love
triangle i mean that was funny that was
stupid it was so stupid it was so funny
it was so funny and so yeah and so it
was so good and so to have another love
triangle but this time between actual
characters i thought that dynamic could
have been really interesting i mean
that's obviously not where they're going
but um yes brett goldstein brett
goldstein for
hercules incredible
yeah so yeah so you know this so from
the comics they become they become bros
uh how are they gonna move the story
forward though do you think in the next
thor
given that they've teased that russell
crowe's character's still alive and he's
kind of a joke like zeus is kind of a
joke and i grew up
studying the greek gods zeus was no joke
so how how are they going to move that
story forward what would you like to see
for thor 5
well this is kind of interesting
you said right zeus we know zeus is not
a joke does that
does that kind of
i feel that there's that that campus
like why did they make zeus such a joke
right do they almost need to rehab him
to show how powerful he is and how
intimidating of force he can actually be
instead of doing baton tricks with the
thunderbolt now what if what if he went
from dad bod to godbod and russell crowe
gets in sick shape for thor 5. and he
realizes because his son abandons him
and teams up with thor he needs to own
it and he totally revives the greek god
we can go that way i mean i don't know
who the villain would be yet but if zeus
was the villain they're gonna need to do
a lot more with him right i mean he's
he's too
he's too silly and funny right now to be
taken seriously as a villain in in my
mind right yeah okay so moving on to the
end credit scene with jane
uh what did you think about that brian
ooh so i think what marvel has been
doing which is really smart is keeping
the players on the chessboard and they
may not be doing this with villains as
much but
you know jane arrives in valhalla she's
like surprised and we're like we're
surprised too we're like oh dang she's
still quote unquote alive when you don't
see a body they're still alive and if we
see them talking on camera they're
definitely still alive so um i thought
it was awesome just to see not only her
but see idris elba there and the fact
that we've now taken a sneak peek at
valhalla we did not see though
odin or loki in that scene so who knows
are they there are they not there i'm
just throwing it out there they at least
they weren't in that scene in any way
shape or form or reference but the fact
that jane is there and that idris is
there means that we could potentially
see them down the road natalie portman
hasn't signed on for another thor yet
but there's so much to do with the
character whether
it's bringing them back in some capacity
or in the comics quite honestly
after this whole um after jane dies thor
actually brings her back to life
with the power of mjolnir and
in case you didn't know this she becomes
the next valkyrie
now she may not be the next valkyrie
because tessa thompson is still there
but she could be something so i'm just
throwing that out to viewers that
there's no way she's off the table yet i
love how
who knows maybe she shows up in our
crazy cameo and they access valhalla and
we're like oh my god her and heimdall
and whoever and that would be a moment
yeah i heard somebody say oh but you're
supposed to to go into valhalla you're
supposed to have died in battle and she
wasn't technically in battle when she
died
but she was still arguing with gore or
sort of like
verbally in battle pleading with so that
technically
she is in valhalla but maybe she's
not in valhalla but
or the gods showed her favor because of
her service as the mighty thor
right well they see these are the movies
right so there there is no such thing as
a technicality especially in comic book
movies where everyone is alive until
they're not alive which is why tony
stark's death meant so much right um
yeah she's still on the table i mean
would you like to see more of her
oh a thousand percent like i said i
didn't i didn't think that i got
enough of her in this one
i didn't i wanted to see her own her
powers longer
and have like a like a longer arc in
terms of watching can and she can do
she can kind of do it all right she can
do the powerful she can do the emotional
stuff
and she and hemsworth have great
chemistry together i've always thought
that even from the first thor they were
one of like my favorite mcu couple
because i thought they were really
kinetic on screen together i thought
they were really great so yeah i would
of course like to see any theories about
you know where it might go knowing that
you know the comics so well well i mean
that that's all that's you know what i
told you is basically what happens in
the comics but i don't
maybe she comes back not as the valkyrie
but as one of the valkyries
um and we know that her and tessa
thompson have such a great relationship
in the movies and they've got a great
vibe going on too um that makes sense as
well but
you know i that that's all that really
the comics have in store it doesn't mean
that we're gonna see it on film like i
said you know it's a reference point but
i when every time you talk about oh i
wanted to see her more i mean she
basically had like a 30 issue arc that
showed off what she was really capable
of showed off her also her kind of
emotional struggle with
being transforming between
mighty thor
and dealing with cancer like we kind of
only saw that transformation once and
yes you could say well that illustrated
the point in the movie but i think we
need to go to it through a journey with
these characters a little longer and i
really love the idea of you saying this
arguably could have been a two-story arc
with both gore the god butcher and jane
um in order to really flesh this out and
make these things more meaningful
because even someone like hella kate
blanche like
she died it like she was an incredible
villain like she needs to still be on
the table if you ask me and so
i'd prefer as things have gone on we
started seeing this in small ways like
baron zemo and from captain america and
winter soldier falcon number soldier
he's still on the table and i think that
we need to see these villains not just
die
after one movie to make to just to have
the idea or the thought that they're
still out there in the world because
that that's also a comic book thingy
yeah what do you you know there's like a
four-hour cut according to taika
would you want to see it
i think here's the thing i know you do
because you are like
and i'm not this is the thing i don't
want people to get misconstrued and
think that i didn't like this movie i
enjoyed it right but there's things that
i wanted to see more of i think you'd be
all in on the four hour cut i'd be a
little concerned because even before
this you know i had
friends in the industry tell me like
that had actually seen the longer
version he's like oh
you didn't see it all i mean there were
reports that there was a dance routine
with with like jeff goldblum and peter
dinklage we didn't get the lena he scene
in the movie as well that was talked
about a lot but because of story and
direction like that's what i'm saying
when i hear all these things after the
fact i'm like could we have just taken
some of the jokes out to put more meat
and potatoes in it when you hear about
some of these things of course a dance
with jeff goldblum and peter dinklage is
not meat and potatoes by any means but i
think the four hour uh
the four hour cut would be fun
but it might as me who
who loves the movie and still enjoys it
i might get frustrated being like
wait like where was the other stuff that
could have been put in here but it would
be fun it would be fun well he called it
monty python-esque so i think it would
get even more absurd but maybe it would
feel more connected
and i think
you know he did say
that
he was like
he he it was weird because he said
there is a four cut that he would want
people to see and yet when people asked
him about the jeff goldblum
peter dinklage scene he's like oh no
that had to get cut out that had i'm
like why did that have to get cut out
but you're willing for people to see the
four hour cut he was like no it wasn't
good enough to make it into the film so
it was a little bit
of a contrasting opinion
i think that the this four hour cut that
obviously stuff comes up interviews i
think that was totally just like the
assembly cut but um like i said i you
know
friends who see the dailies they i don't
bug them during i wait till after the
movie because hey i don't want to know
anything about it quite honestly going
in i want to know about the stuff after
the fact but after the movie came out he
said oh they cut out a lot of stuff
because it was way too joking i'm like
wait it was
i mean you know that taika is gonna push
it i'm like but when i hear someone that
say there were even more
crazy random jokes in this movie i'm
like
that would have been too too much i mean
some people might say like it
it was yeah it would have been too much
it would have been too much i don't want
to say that this was this this was like
almost like a satire of a marvel movie
but in some cases it was like when lady
siff was dead dying on the battlefield
and he's like it was at first serious
and then he's like oh your arm will be
in valhalla like that was funny but it
was like dude
like that's when i knew i should not
take anything in this movie serious ever
if that when that scene happened
well if this if this gives you an idea
where his head is at he apparently you
know what it said at the very end thor
will return apparently he and hemsworth
both went it will no one told us like no
one even talked to us about thor 5 yet
and and then he said and then they said
well would you be interested in thor 5
and he said well only if he was doing no
battle and he was on like a family
vacation like it was called nebraska or
something would i be interested in doing
a thor 5 and i'm like
this is why i love him because you know
what he's like a palette cleanser he
cleanses my palate and i'm like
refreshed after i see his sense of humor
in the mcu
it doesn't need to necessarily
necessarily make sense
oh
no it doesn't it doesn't at all it
doesn't at all it's taika i think we're
going to wrap up this chat
but i want to thank you so much for
joining this has been a blast i got so
like involved in talking to you like i
couldn't even remember my talking points
we were just like flowing and going and
it was it was such fun thank you for
joining can you give yourself
a well-deserved plug and let everybody
know where they can find you yes thanks
nikki um basically what i do is i kind
of cover everything in the tech geek and
space culture whether that's yeah tech
and geek space area so if you're into
iphone reviews or you're into the latest
movie reviews and how those might blend
or even like behind the scenes of how
they made raya i do a lot of different
things like that and so if that's your
you know your jam come on hang out it's
just a youtube.com brian tong and you
can find me by my name and all these
other places but uh that's where you can
find me so thanks for the let me do the
plug i've seen your videos and they're
fantastic you have great energy again
best hair in the business you have like
almost like a thunderbolt i so love
chatting with you
it's so perfect thank you so much we'll
do it again we'll do it again thanks so
much
[Laughter]
which will be your number one movie
again i'm pretty sure about it i know i
know how you are i see i get you now
you totally get me thank you everybody
for watching and i hope you guys had fun
deep diving into thor love and thunder
with us and we will see you on the next
episode bye
you